hello hello and the way she would light  up a room as she walked in  she had this way about her that as soon  as he met her he instantly fell in love  with her  everyone that knew  and met Elle knew how special she was  her laugh was infectious anyone who was  a was around her had a good time  she loved life and had so many amazing  plans for the future she was only just  getting started  Christmas and our family will never be  the same again without her  she was the glue that held this big  family together  we will love and miss her forever our  Ellie May the most beautiful and bright  star out there forever and always  my beautiful Ellie Marlene is the love  of my life  and she is my world my best friend  she will always shine and be beautiful  and bright my alley has never gone